[Music]
what's the toughest conversation you've
ever had to have
hmm
easily every time i have to fire someone
um
i mean like they're all horrible i could
probably think of one specifically i
think that delivering bad news is a trap
for an awkward person because if you're
an awkward person all you want is to be
liked
but if you know that you have bad news
if you know that you're firing someone
or you have bad news to impart you know
they're not going to like you
and so it's impossible to be like i have
to deliver this news and i have to also
sacrifice that fear that i've had my
whole life of not being light because
it's not i'm not going to be liked
that's probably the hardest conversation
oh
man how about you guys i don't want to
talk about it
that's not i mean i for me the the one
that comes to mind right away is uh when
my first marriage ended and having that
conversation so it's delivering bad news
there as well i will say this be because
quite often
as someone who wants to be liked and we
all want to be liked to some certain
extent right
but if the more we want to be like the
more we desire the approval the
veneration the applause of other people
the
the tighter that prison cell is for us
right
in fact we had a boss i remember who was
totally fine with firing people i
wouldn't say that he enjoyed it although
he may have a little bit he got
adrenaline from it for sure and so yeah
vanessa maybe tell us about
the
we when we had a boss when we worked
together in the corporate world who had
no problem at all
having these tough conversations what
makes that person different from us
so i think that power in one word power
so for me
i would always rather be liked and be
seen as powerful like that's no that's a
no-brainer for me yeah but for other
people it's the opposite they are happy
to not be liked if people think they're
impressive and powerful and capable
and so if you're firing someone or
you're having a conversation where
you're the deliverer of bad news that is
the ultimate position of power you don't
care about being liked but you're saying
i'm in control of you and i'm in control
of the news so i think that that power
dynamic is actually what the changes and
we're often trying to sacrifice one of
the other right we're trying to say do i
want to be powerful and respected or do
i want to be liked i think you can be
both but it's really hard yeah it's that
old like for a king you know does the
king want to be loved or do they want to
be feared exactly and there is yeah
there's a there's a balance in within
that um
but yeah he definitely loved the being
feared he got off on being feared
another word for it is uh sociopathic
or narcissistic or narcissistic yeah
yeah i will say that these difficult
conversations that we dread having most
of us dread having
they're usually the conversations that
most need to be had i know the firing of
someone yes the divorce when i left my
corporate career that was a very
difficult conversation to have
and yet
these are the things that allow us to
move forward
it's it's just like the whole free
speech argument it's like no one cares
about protecting speech that we all
agree with like oh ryan i think you're
handsome how dare you
we don't need to protect that free
speech we need to protect the free
speech where it's like oh i don't agree
with that and i think the same thing is
true with these difficult conversations
these are quite often the conversations
worth having having those tough
conversations yes and here's the problem
that we make is these difficult
conversations are the most important
conversations sometimes in our life yeah
right like there are defining moments in
our life so the problem is is people
often will prep for those difficult
conversations with trying to have the
right cues trying to have the right
vocal power they script out the perfect
thing and then they wait to try all that
out for the first time in the
conversation
that is the biggest mistake we make when
trying to communicate better is we wait
for the hard conversations
we we go i want to talk to a va let's
talk about bad news i thought good news
i really want to talk to a vip i really
want to nail that interview and so they
practice for that really hard thing but
then they get into the actual really
hard thing and their adrenaline is
pumping and it's really hard so actually
what i want you to think about is you
should get your cues right when it
doesn't matter
yeah right like the you should forget
practicing with your boss do not
practice these things for a tough
conversation no no i want you to
practice first with someone you don't
know and don't care about in fact you
have an exercise in the book where you
videotape yourself yes no one watches
right that's the absolute best there's
no stakes because it's really hard to
try on cues there's 96 different cues
it's hard to try them on when they're
stakes because you're even more nervous
so i'd rather you try them on and
there's like a ladder here so the very
first place to try them is just with
yourself so videotaping yourself and
coding yourself what cues you're sending
when you're listening do you have
resting bothered face are you a knotter
are you a disgust person do you often
trickle your nose up when you're
listening are you an eyebrow razor are
you a shifter are you a fidgeter i want
you to know what your nervous tells are
i think everyone should know their
nervous tells i think it's incredibly
important it's an empowering piece of
information to know about yourself what
do you do when you're nervous and what
do you do in your life yeah the exercise
i give in the book which i'll share here
this is so powerful
open your webcam
and first answer what did you have for
breakfast yesterday
this is a recall question it's going
you're going to see what you look like
when you recall non-important
information do you look up to the left
are you a fidgeter do you close your
eyes do you purse your lips that's how
you look when you're recalling it's
important to know about yourself the
next question i want you to answer is
what is your most embarrassing moment
and i want you to deliver it to the
camera as if you're sharing it with me
this is what you look like when you're
talking about something recalling
nervousness
how do your cues change do you fidget
more do you fidget less do you freeze
do you show the fear micro expression
where your eyes are really wide do you
use less gestures or more gestures
that's how you look when you're nervous
the third one is the most important i
want you to tell me or pretend you're
telling me a made-up embarrassing story
so i want you to deliver an embarrassing
story that did not actually happen to
you it cannot have happened to you or
someone you know and i want you to
pretend that you're delivering it to me
and try to convince me that that's your
real embarrassing story
that's what you look like when you're
lying
and i think that we should know those
keys about ourselves we should that's
yeah that's powerful yeah this is
awesome did you enjoy this standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free